let's get into hatred mail I know many
of you anxiously waiting for this week's
a tree at mail a fine Rand and Ronald
Reagan had a baby and suckled that child
off the teat of Liberty its cries would
sound a little something like Patriot
man written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America because freedom
some weeks I have a little bit of an
intro or preparation for you for hatred
mail this week I can provide no such
thing I will just play it for you and
see if we can figure it out David I've
never watched your show before and I can
say after watching this video that I
will never watch your show again the
amount of stupidity you have for the
real world is just mind-blowing please
do yourself a favor and learn everything
about a subject before talking about it
if this information gathering process
becomes a routine of yours then I might
consider watching your show again David
sounds like sort of are the worst of
sort person
David's sort like sort of sounds like
the worst are sort of sort of person I
like that I don't know exactly what they
meant but the silver lining here is at
least this hatred said they'd be willing
to check the show out again if I do
exactly what it is that they are saying
hey tree it's often have many many
demands they would be willing to check
the show out again and for that I think
we should applaud that I thought the
message was coherent at least at first
and then it kind of trailed off Pat's
bar for hatred mail is if I can even
remotely understand what it is the
hatred is talking about it's really not
that bad and and generally given what
we've seen I think I do have to agree
remember you can turn hatred mail into
something positive with the membership
coupon code hey tree at 40 every time
you use the coupon code hey tree at 40
at david pakman.com slash membership a
hatred cries that's what I've read on
reddit on the same forum where people
discuss pizza gate and I believe it to
be true